merci monsieur le président ce premier
ministre je voudrais vous parler du
burkina faso
ce pays est miné par le développement du
terrorisme islamique et est au bord de
l'effondrement dès à présent un tiers de
son territoire est aux mains des
jihadistes alors que selon l'onu on
comptait fin août 2 190 mille déplacés
ils seront probablement cinq cent mille
à la fin de l'année 3000 écoles sont
déjà fermés de même que tous les
hôpitaux et dispensaires des zones
concernées
le pire est que l' influence des
terroristes ne cesse de grandir et
désormais ce sont des attaques quasi
quotidiennes qui frappe le pays avec
leurs cortèges de pertes humaines
militaire et civil l'armée nationale et
malheureusement impuissantes à endiguer
cette progression le risque est de voir
le scénario malien se rejouer dans ce
pays et ceci est d'autant plus grave que
le burkina faso n'est pas n'importe quel
pays il est assurément un verrou
stratégique pour bloquer l'expansion du
terrorisme vers les pays du golfe de
guinée
tel que le togo le bénin la côte
d'ivoire et le ghana qui s'inquiètent à
juste titre les pays de la cedeao ont
d'ailleurs solennellement tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé lors d'un sommet
extraordinaire mi septembre à
ouagadougou sur le premier ministre mais
question à cet égard sont simples
premièrement cinq ans après le succès de
l'opération serval qui avait permis
d'empêcher le renversement de l'état au
mali vu la gravité de la situation
burkina faso que compte entreprendre la
france le président de la république a
annoncé à la fin de l'été je cite un
nouveau partenariat pour la sécurité et
la stabilité dans le sahel
ce partenariat peut assurément concerner
des pays européens mais également la
cedeao qui s'est notamment engagé à
financer une nouvelle force régionale à
côté et du g5 sahel pouvez vous nous
éclairer à ce sujet et enfin dans la
mesure où plus que le fondamentalisme
religieux
on le sait c'est la pauvreté qui fait
basculer la population le terrorisme
n'at-il pas lieu de développer plus
fortement et spécifiquement l'aide au
développement dans ce pays en lien avec
tous les acteurs possibles sur le plan
national mais aussi international je
vous remercie